bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france qui sont les auteurs
de cette prise les mêmes qui avaient
arrêté il ya neuf mois l'ancien
président boubacar kéita conduit lui
aussi dans le même compte cattier et
contrant par la suite à la démission est
ce que vous direz qu'on revit la halle
les événements d'août dernier
bon je dirais qu'on s'enfonce un peu
plus dans la crise
il n'y a plus de pilote dans l'avion
c'est clair et net au mali il n'y a que
des terroristes dans un cockpit
en gros l'agent est dérouté et on sait
pas où il va arriver c'est le crash
possible c'est vraiment très très grave
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au mali pour
la république malienne qui montre
vraiment mais bien un essoufflement on a
l'impression de devoir en direct la mort
de deux des institutions d'un pays qui
malheureusement depuis l'indépendance de
1958 60 et bien et aller de mal en pis
avec une succession de coups d'état de
putsch est souvent évidemment militaire
mené la plupart du temps par des
généraux ou des petits colonel depuis la
caserne de catic personnellement je
connais bien puisque j'ai fait plusieurs
reportages là bas on peut tu es parce
que il y avait eu pression de l'armée
malienne notamment grâce aux formations
européennes
vous savez de le huitième est bien là
l'armée malienne était un petit peu
montée en gamme ces dernières années
pour justement défendre le pays
malheureusement on a l'impression que ce
sont certains militaires frustré
peut-être alcoolisées malheureusement ce
n'est pas une armée très discipliné je
peux vous le je peux vous l'affirmer il
ya beaucoup d'alcool qui qui circulent
dans les casernes peut être un peu trop
et on peut on peut d'ailleurs le
craindre pour ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est pitoyable
et c'est surtout est bien là
sauf que le bali s'enfonce dans une
crise dans une spirale négative et on
voit pas comment il en sortira si ce
n'est malheureusement un sursaut de la
population on peut s'attendre à des
manifestations dans les rues de bamako
ces prochains jours on peut ça semble
s'attendre aussi à une tutelle de la
cedeao mais c'est très délicat parce que
évidemment s'occuper s'ingérer d'un pays
en afrique c'est compliqué pour mille
raisons
la france va rester observatrice on le
sait pour c on va dire pour son vieux
passif colonial donc c'est un pays qui
s'enfonce et puis et bien on peut
craindre que évidemment ce soit les
islamistes qui en profitent notamment
une figure très connue là-bas qui est
l'imam dicko qui attend patiemment de
son côté qui est de plus en plus
populaire et jusque là il ne pouvait pas
participer à la vie politique malienne
puisque la la la la constitution
actuelle ne lui permettait pas on a
l'impression que là on lui on lui on lui
déroule le tapis rouge
que cherchent ces militaires qui ont
donc enlevé hier le président et le
premier ministre de transition vous dit
d'ailleurs que finalement cette
institution militaire n'est peut-être
pas si unique c'est aujourd'hui au mali
bon allez elle est même complètement
désunie les militaires maliens l'armée
ça représente 15 à les 10 15 milles
vingt mille hommes maxi c'est drôle
parce que quand j'étais la dernière fois
reportages notamment à kati on m'avait
dit au mali a plus de généraux que de
simples amis
nous avons malheureusement perdu lass
analyse que c'est une guerre de dégoût
c'est une guerre oui je disais que
c'était une guerre d'ego au sein de
l'armée malienne
on entend souvent dans 2 depuis le
l'opinion publique et au mali il ya plus
de généraux que de simples militaire et
bien on est en train de le voir
actuellement ce sont des luttes de
intestines au sein de l'armée de petits
chefaillons qu'ils veulent alors on
entend beaucoup ici et là qui veulent le
pouvoir tout simplement pour améliorer
le quotidien aussi de leur clan c'est
terrible c'est un pays quand même l'un
des plus pauvres du monde
certes qui a des richesses naturelles
mais aujourd'hui l'un des plus pauvres
du monde
et vous avez tout simplement des gens
qui essayent est bien de sauver leur
famille et on le voit et on le ressent
dans cette armée malienne complètement
gangréné par la corruption
je vous disais tout à l'heure il ya des
problèmes d'alcool mais c'est une
évidence pour être souvent mettre
souvent rapprochée de que ce soit de la
minus ma de l'armée de l'onu ou de
markale s'est régulièrement qu'on
entendait ces critiques
il ya un manque de discipline dans
l'armée malienne malgré des efforts et
malgré quelques progrès qui font que qui
fait que aujourd'hui vous avez 7 izany
7,7 cette vision pitoyable que donne le
pays dans un moment malheureusement
crucial où tous les efforts devraient
être menées contre le la menace
terroriste
on sait très bien que aujourd'hui encore
et bien que ce soit une partie l'armée
malienne les armées africaines et
françaises lutte d'arrache-pied pour
pour mettre un terme à cette menace
terroriste notamment contre le groupe
état islamiste à l'est et puis contre al
qaïda et les groupes affiliés au nord
vous avez encore aujourd'hui des otages
dont un otage français
enfin c'est une situation qui semble
dépasser à la fois les autorités
maliennes
et puis je pense de plus en plus la
diplomatie française on est face à un
cas exceptionnel
sans parler de la diplomatie africaine
qui va être à pied d'oeuvre ces
prochains jours mais on peut douter de
l'efficacité jusque là n'ont réussi qu'à
kaka accentue la zizanie
donc c'est un pays qui part en lambeaux
et on peut craindre
évidemment dans un dans un tel marasme
et bien que ce soient les plus
extrémistes qui qui en profitent et
d'ailleurs une fois de plus ils sont
trahis sont prêts à prendre le pouvoir
et ils sont soutenus par une population
qui est à la fois lassé de ces années de
crise vous avez une des politiques qui
ne qui sont totalement jeu pour la
plupart ils ont tous été au pouvoir ils
n'ont pas su relever le pays c'est le
cas de de l'ancien président boubacar
keita c'est le cas d'à peu près tous ces
ministres qui se sont succédé les uns
les autres
le président et le premier ministre de
transition ont été interpellés
hier quelques heures après l annonce de
la nomination du nouveau gouvernement
qu'est ce qui a déplu à priori aux
militaires dans la constitution dans
cette équipe gouvernementale
d'après ce qu'on dit c'est que en gros
les les les proches de la junte de du
colonel assimi aux états qui était donc
le vice président de la transition qui
avait mené le putsch en août 2020 contre
le président boubacar keita avait évincé
de ce gouvernement et et que sans doute
monsieur assi meego ita ce sens se
sentait un petit peu comment dire
éloigné du pouvoir et et d'ailleurs
c'était un peu plus puisque à priori
cette transition militaire militaro
politique devait lentement à les verts
et bien un système politique civile
rendre le rendre le pouvoir à la
population malienne en organisant des
élections on voit bien que là c'est pas
du tout l'objectif d'aider quelques
colonel qui mène 7
cette action et qui mêle ce ce
continuité de putsch parce que
finalement on est dans un push permanent
actuellement au mali rien ne semble nous
donner l'impression que que des
élections vont être organisées le pays
part à vau l'eau
il ya vraiment plus de pilote dans
l'avion et ça et ça c'est quand même
assez nouveau parce que jusque là vous
aviez eu des des coups d'état et puis
assez rapidement c'était le cas à
l'époque par exemple du grand président
toumani touré qui est décédé il ya
quelques temps qui avait fait un putsch
et puis très vite qui avait rendu le
pouvoir aux civils
et il y avait eu les élections
démocratiques et des alternances
politiques
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que on est
au bout de cette logique là et on se
demande ce qui va les voir après merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de réagir
sur notre antenne françois-xavier
frôlant je rappelle que cette
journaliste spécialiste du manège rappel
c'est le titre de votre dernier ouvrage
manière au delà du jihad